sticky short red rice it's a perfect
dish to share with loved ones or to be
the show stopper at a party what's up
everyone i'm chef jj johnson and today
i'm making my famous sticky rice stuffed
with some short ribs this dish i'm
making today is inspired by my childhood
i grew up with rice we ate rice with
everything and i'm incorporating some of
my childhood memories into this dish one
of my earliest
memories of sticky rice is when i was in
the sixth grade i went to one of my
friends houses and they just had like
this amazing
flavorful rice that i never had and it
happened to be sticky rice i went home
and ran to my mom and i was like mom mom
i went i went i went stick your eyes on
sticky rice and she was like i don't
know how to make that rice we keep it
really basic here so the inspiration for
the flavors of the sticky rice come from
my travels and my childhood from india
and singapore
the curry in this dish
comes from my background of
my grandfather's from barbados so i used
to grow up with light indian curry all
the time so just incorporating and
pulling
making it super tasty and flavorful
sticky rice gets its unique texture from
the starch well when i'm cooking at home
i'm all about the music i'm into 90's
hip hop and r b i grew up in it happy
times but it's all about the good vibes
like i feel like when you give good
vibes in the food and you're smiling
like i'm smiling stirring oh sherbs are
amazing they're like super fatty great
flavor
i know you're freaking out right now you
look at this piece of meat in the
supermarket and you're like not for me
or i don't know what to do with it it's
easy when you have short ribs it needs
to have a really good amount of salt
because you need to braise the short rib
and that's what's going to make it nice
and tender
have really good flavor
like short rib is that piece of protein
that you want in your refrigerator that
you want to cook with just just trust me
just trust me
[Music]
i grew up eating short ribs oxtails
raised lamb i always felt like it was
missing something until i fell in love
with the ingredient cinnamon and once i
put that in my short rib or my oxtails
or my braised lamb
it was incredible so i'm sharing that
with you that's the secret ingredient
here food became part of my dna through
my grandmother in really early age of
life but my grandmother made food look
really fun
so instead of me watching cartoons i was
in the kitchen cooking so this braising
technique
is a traditional braising technique it
has red wine in it but my flavor profile
in here is based for my travel so a
little bit of orange juice cinnamon
stick thyme bay leaf jalapeno so i'm
mixing it up a little bit
so foo can teach you about culture and
sometimes you don't need to travel
somewhere to learn about the culture of
that place so if you're thinking about
going somewhere go eat at a restaurant
that you think represents that place
and that food will start to tell you
about that culture i mean when i travel
or my friends travel or my family
travels the first thing you talk about
is where are we going to go eat what are
we going to do and it always is around
food in that place
the world loves rice because it's like a
field trip
it bounces it moves it goes in all these
different places this is how people move
and if you really look at rice
you'll see that certain cultures eat
certain races
sticky rice today you're taking a trip
into southeast asia
rice is
culture across the board it fuels
communities doesn't matter how much
money you have in your bank account we
all eat rice it connects everybody this
is the perfect dish to bring to any of
your holiday parties if you really want
to show off come on take a bite with me
look at that
rice's culture baby
[Music]
you